back in 2007 collecting comics
wearing superhero merch and researching
particle physics might have seemed
strictly reserved for nerds
it was the year after the original x-men
trilogy had wrapped in movie theaters
and the year that the tobey maguire
starring spider-man trilogy ended with
emo spidey
that september a show about four geeky
scientists and one beautiful aspiring
actress debuted not with a bang
but with a collective co-created by two
and a half men mastermind chuck lorre
and bill prady who worked on series like
star trek voyager
and married with children the big bang
theory had creative powerhouses behind
it
but it didn't take off like a homemade
bottle rocket until a bit later in the
game
the big bang theory was riffing on nerd
culture before
nerd culture became mainstream following
a lukewarm response to the first few
seasons the series eventually found its
audience and broke
several records in 2018 the show's four
leads
jim parsons johnny galecki simon helberg
and kunal nayer were the highest paid
actors on tv
just one of the many ways that the big
bang theory is a lot like friends
as many critics have stated in 2019 12
years after its premiere on cbs
the big bang theory became the longest
running multi-camera sitcom
surpassing the previous record of 275
episodes
set by cheers but by then parsons had
already turned down a reported 50
million dollars to make
two more seasons which is the real
reason why the big bang theory ended
after the 12th season aired in 2019
as both celebration and mockery of geek
culture
the show usually wasn't subtle about its
references but there were probably a few
things you never noticed in the tv hits
final episode
the big bang theory first aired at the
peak of 2000's fashion
when ugg boots and pleated miniskirts
were the look
12 years later the trends may have
changed but the show's costume
department snuck in a few references to
the pilot to show how the characters
lives have come full circle
sheldon's t-shirts have always been a
talking point
especially now that superhero merch is
more present at big box chain stores
than ever
in the first half of the finale the
change constant
sheldon is wearing one of his classic
t-shirts bearing the green lantern logo
however the t-shirt is deliberately
faded emphasizing the passing of time
and the fact that his clothing is yet
another thing that he can't keep from
changing
in the second half of the finale the
stockholm syndrome
sheldon wears a t-shirt showing multiple
superhero logos
which is unusual for him this matches
the feel of the episode as a conclusion
of the whole series
with sheldon finally learning to
appreciate his friends instead of
thinking about himself all the time
sheldon isn't the only one whose t-shirt
is talking
in the final shot look closer at penny's
light blue top with purple flowers
and you'll see that it's the same one
she wore when she first met
sheldon and leonard penny also wore this
top when leonard asked her on a date
that led to them rekindling their
relationship in season five
it's a nice way to connect the pivotal
moments in a relationship that has been
at the heart of the show
from day one there's another penny
leonard connection between the pilot and
finale
in the stockholm syndrome penny reveals
that she's pregnant
the couple's decision over whether to
have children is a thread throughout the
final season
but it's actually been in the cards for
a lot longer you likely never noticed in
the big bang theory's first episode that
leonard predicted this plot line in the
pilot
immediately after meeting penny he told
sheldon our babies will be smart and
beautiful
we'll have to wait 20 years or so for
the inevitable revival to find out
whether or not this assessment is true
but it also marked an unusual moment for
sheldon
his response to leonard's prediction is
not to mention imaginary
even nobel prize-winning theoretical
physicists can't be right all the time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one